I told you last week that the Senate
Intelligence Committee had subpoenaed
Donald Trump jr. to go and talk to them
and the reason why as far as we know is
that because no matter how many times
Donald Trump likes to say it the
investigations aren't over and later in
the show I'll give you a list of the
open investigations I also told you that
the fact that there's a subpoena at all
likely means that the Senate
Intelligence Committee already requested
that Don Jr appear and that he ignored
those requests causing the need for a
subpoena and indeed Republicans on the
Senate Intel committee are telling us
that that's the case now why would the
Senate Intelligence Committee even want
to talk to Don junior because it appears
as though he lied to them through his
teeth and Republicans and Democrats
don't like being lied to the Republicans
and Democrats will become instantly
bipartisan when they feel like their
authority is not being respected and
they're not being taken seriously Don
jr. said that he knew nothing about the
Moscow Trump tower part project that he
had nothing to do with it he wasn't
talking to anyone about it and yet
Michael Cohen Trump's personal attorney
later revealed under oath that he
briefed both Don junior and Ivanka Trump
about that project about ten times what
else did Don junior lie about during the
Senate Intel testimony that he gave I
don't know but that's exactly what the
Senate Intelligence Committee now wants
to find out however there is at least
one sitting Senator Lindsey Graham who
is a known trump brown-nosing sycophant
who's urging Don jr. to just ignore the
legal subpoena from the same Senate on
which Lindsey Graham sits this is
against the law
Lindsey Graham is suggesting that Don
jr. break the law so that he doesn't
have to speak to his colleagues in the
Senate check this clip out from Fox News
on Sunday it was all a setup I think
that we'll know more and what no more
here soon
what was it also a setup to set up
Donald Trump jr. I mean what is this
subpoena of Donald Trump jr. coming out
of your colleagues and the Senate Intel
committee as I understand it the
subpoena relates to what Michael Kors
said about some meetings and about the
the Trump Tower in Russia all I can say
is Richard burr is a very good friend
he's trying hard to be bipartisan
but anything based on what Michael Cohen
said is worthless testimony Michael
Cohen is a worthless witness and if I
were Donald Trump jr. his lawyer I would
tell him you don't need to go back into
this environment anymore you've been
there for hours and hours and hours and
nothing being alleged here changes the
outcome of the Moller investigation I
would call it a day so first of all if
Lindsay believes that Michael Cohen lied
under oath when he testified then Cohen
should be punished for that now do you
think that after everything and everyone
that's gone down for lying to
investigators and lying to Congress
don't you think that if Michael Cohen
did lie to Congress about Don Jr's
involvement that they would be charging
Cohen and potentially extending his
prison sentence I mean it's all
completely ridiculous at face value but
you might imagine Oh Lindsey Graham is
gonna get crushed for this right I mean
for a sitting senator to get away with
suggesting that legal subpoenas from his
own Senate be ignored he's gonna get
crushed by that right no he's not and
the reason why is that the same
Republicans who want to shut down
government departments the same
Republicans who say that they are about
small government if you believe that
almost any government action is an
overreach then you like the idea of
taking power away from the government
and from the Senate Lindsey Graham as
crazy as what he's suggesting rot Don
junior do is just break the law right
ignore the subpoena Lindsey Graham is
going to be praised for his suggestion
because so-called
small government conservatives and
trumpets don't see this as Lindsey
suggesting Don jr. break the law they
see this as Lindsey Graham doing the
small government conservative thing of
limiting the power of the Senate by
suggesting people ignore subpoenas which
of course they say are
bogus witch-hunt subpoenas and this sort
of comes down to a fundamental
philosophical difference that makes it
safe for Lindsey Graham to suggest on
jr. break the law and unfortunately this
is how a government becomes an oligarchy
this is how a government moved towards
autocracy and this is the theme of the
Trump administration the Senate has
subpoena powers senators choosing to
question their own subpoena power over
the family of the President of the
United States is another way to usher in
or to allow or to look the other way
about presidential autocracy and
authoritarianism and I genuinely wonder
does Trump have something on Lindsey
Graham and I know every time we talk
about Lindsey someone will write to me
they'll say David Lindsey Graham has to
do what Trump wants because if he
doesn't Trump will reveal that Lindsey
Graham is gay I don't know if that's
true it's been a rumor in DC DC for
decades it's not unique to Trump that
could be something he's holding over
Lindsey Graham's head I just don't see
that I think that there has to be
something else that explains to us why
Lindsey Graham has become totally
subservient to Trump is it some implicit
or intimated promise about Lindsey's
role in a second Trump term maybe I
don't know but he has to go he's up for
re-election in 2020 by the way but it's
a very safe seat currently and he's
probably going to get reelected